cameo's classic cars and a made-up brand
of cigarettes before the MCU there was
the Tarantino verse a world jam-packed
with Easter eggs that you won't want to
miss
Quentin Tarantino is fond of bringing
recurring elements across this
filmography with one of the most famous
examples being fictional brands or the
most prominent is Red Apple cigarettes
introduced in Pulp Fiction the fictional
cigarette brand is smoked by several
different characters in the 1994 film
a pack of red apples Builders
the cigarette brand also makes
appearances in the hateful eight and the
Tarantino Helm sequence from 1995's
Anthology film for rooms other notable
and film advertising for Red Apple
cigarettes includes a Japanese billboard
glimpsed in Kill Bill vol 1 and an end
credit scene from Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood
one of the big mysteries of Kill Bill
vol 1 revolved around the name of Uma
Thurman's vengeful protagonist referred
to in the film and its marketing as the
bride whenever the character's name was
mentioned in volume 1 in the first half
of 2004's Kill Bill volume 2 and was
audibly censored to maintain the mystery
hi honey
um
what's your name
however the bride's full name is
revealed in volume 1 long before the
bill in a Cell driver announces it in
volume 2 just need to be really focusing
on the screen to see it after regaining
Consciousness in an El Paso Hospital the
bride orders a one-way plane ticket to
travel to Okinawa intending to obtain a
katana from retired swordmaker Hattori
Hanzo in a blink and you'll miss it
moment the printed plane ticket clearly
has the name Beatrix kiddo displayed in
the top corner
Tarantino made his feature-length
directorial debut with 1992's Reservoir
Dogs a relatively low budget crime film
following a group of Thieves in the
aftermath of a disastrous jewelry store
heist one of the many elements that made
the film Stand Out was Tarantino's
decision not to show the actual robbery
in a flashback viewers briefly glimpse a
chaotic aftermath and judging by a
mistake in that sequence perhaps it's
better that most of the film is dialogue
inside a nondescript Warehouse as Mr
Pink recounts how he barely escaped from
the police after the botched Heist he
can be seen sprinting down a busy Los
Angeles street with a cops in Pursuit on
foot after pushing his way past two
pedestrians the film crew's reflection
is visible in a storefront window in the
background from the camera crew
themselves to a boom mic used to capture
the chaotic audio a seasoned filmmaker
likely would have seen such potential
for error and employed some kind of
obfuscation technique but since
Tarantino was a rookie his mistakes
survived the final cut in a way perhaps
that exemplifies the hurried thrill of
early 90s Indie Cinema
Tarantino has included nods and homages
to Spaghetti Westerns in his work for
years and leaned into these influences
for his own Django Unchained the 2012
film stars Jamie Foxx is the titular
freed slave determined to rescue his
wife Broom-Hilda from the sadistic
Plantation on her Calvin candy Jose is a
man interested in buying a slave for
gladiatorial fights Django meets with
candy who is in competition with a rival
slave owner played by veteran Spaghetti
Western actor Franco Nero Nero played
the original version of the character in
the 1966 spaghetti western film Django
an a visual reference to Nero's
spaghetti western he wears bright white
gloves a nod to Nero's iteration of
Django having his hands maimed over the
course of the 1966 film
d j a n g o
the D is silent
I know
with Kill Bill being told out of
chronological order the first assassin
that the bride takes a revenge on isn't
Bernita green as shown in the volume one
opening but Iran ishii in the four years
that the bride was rendered Comatose by
the cabal of global assassins orensei's
Powers one of the most powerful Yakuza
leaders in Japan after the bride cuts
through Oren's private Army at a Tokyo
restaurant the two former Associates
engage in their own private duel with a
wren correctly predicting how long the
fight will last while iren is surprised
that the bride wields a sword forged by
the retired Hanzo she estimates that the
impending duel won't last five minutes
then again
is correct in her prediction but not in
the way that she anticipated the ride
cuts off the top of her head killing her
after a hard-fought battle the length of
the sword fight is exactly 4 minutes and
59 seconds fulfilling Loren's lethal
prophecy
the most prominent storyline in
Tarantino's Pulp Fiction is one that
follows Hitman Vincent Vega and Jules
Winfield through Los Angeles while
retrieving a briefcase belonging to
their employer Marcellus Wallace Vincent
and Jules get into a gunfight with an
unnamed character looking to avenge his
friends surprising the two assassins a
character completely unloads a pistol at
them but every bullet strikes the wall
behind Vincent and jewels instead in an
oversight that made it into the final
film the bullet holes in the wall behind
Vincent and jewels are present before
the shooting even begins this suggests
that the scene of Vincent and Jules
talking in front of the bullet ridden
wall was filmed before much of the
following sequence the claims from
Jewels at divine intervention saved him
and Vincent for Mortal harm as a bit
undercut by the knowledge that the
bullet holes were there all along
the opening title sequence the 1997's
Jackie Brown sets the tone for
Tarantino's adaptation of Elmore
Leonard's 1992 novel rum punch from its
grainy color saturated cinematography
and Pam Greer's casting to the 1973
Bobby Womack song across 110th Street
Tarantino pays direct homage to 70s
black exploitation Cinema the memorable
sequence would later be featured in a
direct callback by Tarantino and Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood Jackie Brown
opens with the titular protagonist
moving confidently through a brightly
colored tiled hallway in LAX before
breaking into Iran to board with flight
passengers on time at the gate the same
hallway is featured in once upon a time
when Rick Dalton and Cliff Booth make
their triumphant return to Los Angeles
with Rick's new wife Francesca in both
sequences the characters exude a sense
of cool as they move through the airport
quietly hinting at their status quo
before their respective narratives kick
into high gear
given how the late actor and martial
artist is depicted in Once Upon a Time
Tarantino has a complicated stance
regarding the legacy of Bruce Lee
however Lee received a decidedly more
favorable nod and Kill Bill vol 1 with a
bride's choice in fashion during her
stay in Tokyo from her cruise through
the city on her motorcycle to her
memorable sword fights in the House of
Blue leaves the bride wears a black and
bright yellow tracksuit and helmet
evocative of Lee this iconic outfit is a
visual homage to the martial art
Legend's similar Ensemble and is
posthumously released final film Game of
Death in 1978. the ride's iteration of
the yellow and black outfit would become
one of the most recognizable images of
the character where they're wearing the
track suits on the volume 1 theatrical
poster how would the bride bear against
Cliff Booth possibly better than Bruce
Lee did
ah
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood Blends
real-life figures and true events in the
1960s entertainment scene with fictional
characters and twists on established
history all in service to Tarantino's
Love Letter to 1969 Los Angeles a prime
example of the blur between actual
history and Tarantino's imagination
occurs when Rick Dalton takes an
extended sojourn in Italy starring
European films among the filmmakers that
Rick works with while in Europe is a
real director one amusingly name dropped
in Tarantino's 2009 film Inglorious
Bastards while infiltrating a Nazi film
Premiere in Paris Allied Soldier Donnie
donovitz uses the Alias Antonio
margariti while posing as an Italian
director at the event Antonio margariti
is an actual Italian filmmaker who
directed feature films from 1960 to
1989. he's also credited and Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood for a casting Rick in
the fictional movie operancioni Dynamite
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood is a
lavish painstakingly painful Recreation
of Los Angeles in 1969 drawing from
Tarantino's own memories of the city one
of the most prominent elements he
includes in the film are the classic
cars that Cliff Booth drives around La
one belonging to himself and the other
to his best friend and boss Rick Dalton
and obtaining these throwback
automobiles Tarantino Revisited some of
the cars he had memorably used in his
past projects Rico chauffeured around
the city in his yellow 1966 Cadillac
Coupe Deville by Cliff after receiving a
DUI prior to the events of the film that
car was previously driven by Mr blonde
in 1992's Reservoir Dogs the actual car
is owned by Michael Madsen who
personally lent it to the production
Cliff himself meanwhile drives a blue
1968 Volkswagen Karmann Ghia same-making
model previously driven by the bride in
Kill Bill vol 2.
much like Alfred Hitchcock and other
directors before him Tarantino has made
it a point to cameo in many of his
movies it's a fun tidbit for Tarantino
fans to look out for and one where he
might have a slight advantage over other
filmmakers after all Tarantino
considered himself an actor for many
years and has starred in films like From
Dusk Till Dawn and Destiny turns on the
radio appearing as Mr Brown and
Reservoir Dogs Tarantino delivered the
film's opening Riff on Madonna and was
quickly dispatched in Pulp Fiction the
filmmaker played coffee loving Jimmy who
was willing to help with the body
disposal as long as it went down before
his wife Bonnie got home Tarantino
briefly popped up as a bar owner in
Death Proof and Django Unchained brought
along what might have been the most
sizable role he gave himself and
explosives obsessed Australian one
overlooked role is in the closing
segment of four rooms in which he lays
out the terms of a bloody wager inspired
by an old Alfred Hitchcock Presents
episode more subtle Tarantino cameos
include a voice on an answering machine
in Jackie Brown a Dead Nazi and
Inglorious Bastards and narration for
the hateful eight they have a cameo in
Hollywood supposedly that's him
screaming cut at the end of The Dalton
commercial
all right
and he killed bills some think he was
one of the crazy 88.
though it isn't explicitly stated within
the films themselves Tarantino has
created familial links between some of
the figures in his filmography Mr
blonde's real name in Reservoir Dogs is
revealed to be Vic Vega whom Tarantino
has claimed to be the brother of Vincent
Vega from Pulp Fiction in various
interviews over the years Tarantino has
alluded to the fact that he once had an
idea for a Vega Brothers movie that
would bring Michael Madsen and John
Travolta's characters together like many
Tarantino ideas it never came to
fruition Tarantino's pension to weave
hidden family histories would later
continue with his historical films
ambassadors Michael fassbender's British
intelligence officer Archie Hickox is
related to duplicitous Outlaw English
Pete Hickox and hateful eight as for
recurring names in Tarantino's initial
films it's no secret that he wrote his
earliest scripts during overlapping
periods some with the expectation that
they might not get made it's
unsurprising then that Jimmy and Pulp
Fiction and Mr White and Reservoir Dogs
share the surname dimmick and Tom
sizemore's Natural Born Killers
detective and Blondes parole officer and
Reservoir Dogs are both scagnetti what
may have started as unintended script
shorthand it seems has become a
Tarantino trademark
one of Tarantino's favorite
collaborators in recent years has been
Kurt Russell who appeared prominently in
the hateful eight and Once Upon a Time
in Hollywood the two first got together
for Death Proof with Russell playing
against type as a serial killer named
stuntman Mike who preys young women
using his own modified car as a murder
weapon Death Proof contains several
references to Russell's own long-running
career all while subverting audiences
expectations about his tendency to play
heroic roles when stuntman Mike
introduces himself he reveals that he
previously worked long ago as a stuntman
on the television series The Virginian
as a child actor one of Russell's
earliest roles was on an episode of The
Virginian with the reference being a nod
to Russell's acting Origins a more
subtle reference to Russell's career and
Death Proof is his character Jack
Burton's white tank top from Big Trouble
in Little China hung up on the wall of
the Austin Dive Bar where he stalks his
prey